before we got on to central we make a
mark story there on Unilever well said I
don't think anybody saw that one coming
I mean mr. Pohlman has been in the
headlines he's he because he fended off
that Kraft bid and then responded with a
sort of multi-step program to try and
get the Unilever share price going I
think he's actually doing a pretty good
job in that respect though some
shoulders were critical why did he wait
to do with those things until Kraft
Heinz had turned up so that that's
probably begged a few questions but it'd
be ten in that you'd be over ten years
if he'd done that's if he does another
18 months that compared to the five and
a half year average for the footsie
right now and also a good clean
succession plan compare and contrast the
London Stock Exchange group perhaps it's
very interesting we're on to central
canal eight hundred and twenty three
thousand UK customers gone since the end
of June I mean that's a working number
but it's North America that's actually
the bigger problem when the UK profits
the chief executives century ian conners
stated are actually in line with
expectations despite the customer losses
because of cost-cutting the UK business
operations have suffered a little bit
but what's gone wrong in America is
rather hard to divine other needs the
gap is so big they blend competition and
the old come out of mild weather as well
which is in a problem bit of a weak one
if you're truth be told now course
centrica still has well over a million
small shareholders how nervous
all they'd have been out about their
dividend I think they will be I mean the
dividend yield on the face of it is
around eight and a half to nine percent
now which given that the return on cash
is not 0.5 you can get about 1.3 percent
on a UK attaining a government gilt
eight point seven it's a massive number
it's a very tempting number but you
clearly need to think about how much
risk you're taking to try and get that
number and we've seen how much today
because the share price is taking an
absolute pounding in calm the chief
executive himself I mean he's in his
third year in the role is he gonna be
dangerous I'm sure some questions will
be asked about his pay packet is
inevitabie things our under these
circumstances it was about 4.2 million
last year he's determined clearly to
keep that dividend which is gonna be a
key support for the stock I mean the
profit shortfall today was roughly
twenty percent the shares went down
fifteen and I suspect the dividend is
providing a little bit of support there
he already has been involved in cutting
the dividend twice
partly cuz of the situation inherited
from his predecessor Sam Laidlaw so I
think he will fight tooth and claw to
keep that dividend free cash flow is
about two billion the dividend is about
six hundred and seventy million so the
cover at the moment cover is actually
pretty good
providing of course any move away from
standard variable tariffs and regulatory
pressure doesn't put a third the squeeze
on that cash flow what about the fact
that these shares have come off so much
I mean it used to be rare for a footsie
stock to fall like this and as you
pointed out in the note to clients today
we've had nine incidents this year where
a footsie company has fallen more than
two yeah I mean we got a lot last year
around the round the referendum book but
10% moves in footsie stocks really like
to think shouldn't happen because
they're well researched well understood
it's not a great feather in the cap of
the broken community either but I think
it is the sign perhaps the markets just
getting a little bit twitchy you know
anything that you're burberry an
investment for the future wasn't
well-received Centrica shocks and
profits disappointment not well received
I think the market is becoming
increasingly intolerant of
disappointment and is becoming much more
short term momentum focus now it's a
strategy it's working so all of the
headline index is calm there's a lot of
churn underneath and an emphasis on that
and also just herding into a select
numerous successful stocks could mean
we're nearing the top perhaps all right
Russ mole from AJ both could see thanks
to that